solo necesito un bolígrafo así promulgó
donald trump algunas de sus políticas
más polémicas ahora joe biden tiene la
intención de eliminar las necesitamos
más acción más bipartidismo y
necesitamos movernos con rapidez
necesitamos movernos rápido vaivenes
para cumplir con esa promesa en su
primer día en la casa blanca pretende
lanzar una orden ejecutiva para volver a
adherirse al acuerdo de parís así como
reinstaurar algunas normas para combatir
el cambio climático también restaurar
zonas declaradas como monumentos
nacionales cuyo estatus fue eliminado
por la casa blanca de trump y volverá a
revisar el impacto medioambiental de los
proyectos de oleoductos así como
revertir el incentivo a las
perforaciones de petróleo en altamar
bailén también prevé acabar con las
restricciones de viaje a los países de
mayoría musulmana
tranquis o inicialmente prohibir la
entrada en eeuu a todos los musulmanes
aunque finalmente optó por una versión
menos extrema de la medida también
planea un decreto en el que las agencias
de migración deberán conseguir reunir a
los niños separados de sus familias en
la
como resultado de la política de 'cero
tolerancia' de trump más de 3000 niños
se vieron afectados y cientos de ellos
todavía están lejos de sus familias
además se espera que biden impulse una
serie de decretos relacionados con la
pandemia incluyendo el tapabocas
obligatorio a las instalaciones
federales y la detención de los
desalojos y pagos de créditos durante la
crisis aparte de lo que pueda hacer con
su bolígrafo muchas de las metas
políticas de vaivén necesitan el apoyo
del congreso un prospecto prometedor
dado que los demócratas controlan tanto
el senado como la cámara de
representantes